>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> These extremely rare
but damaged motion pictures
of Mark Twain were taken at his
home in Connecticut in 1909,
a year before his death.
A copy of the film, along with
first editions and thousands
of the celebrated writer's
letters and manuscripts,
are part of the Mark
Twain Project.
Its aim is to painstakingly
edit and publish the bulk
of Twain's huge output.
Twain's daughter bequeathed
her father's papers
to the University of
California at Berkeley in 1962.
The extensive collection is
hidden away in small offices
on the top floor of
Bancroft Library.
For three decades, eight editors
have been pouring over more
than 10,000 letters,
plus notebooks,
story and book manuscripts
and newspaper clippings,
seeking to find the real
Mark Twain and to make all
of his work accurate
and accessible.
>> This is your literary
heritage here in our files.
It has to be edited, it has
to be preserved in some form
that is going to be
transmittable to the future.
>> Robert Hirst,
the general editor,
has devoted his entire
professional life since 1967
to Twain, whom he sees
as a towering talent
in language and humor.
>> I still hear my editors
laughing out loud down the hall
because they're reading
something
which they've probably
read a dozen times before,
but is still alive
and still funny,
no matter how many
times you read it.
>> Many academics would argue
that Twain is still
America's best loved,
perhaps its best writer.
Professor Frederick
Crews recently retired
from Berkeley's English
department.
>> Mark Twain appeals to
academics and non-academics
to a degree that you can't find
matched in any other writer.
He grew up with the country.
He represents the
Midwest, the Far West,
even the New England
establishment.
He went from being a
rough frontier humorists
to being the darling
of genteel culture.
Which of course he made fun of.
>> Robert Pack Browning,
another of the project editors,
is convinced Twain is
worth special treatment
as an American writer
and personality.
Using materials from
Berkeley's collection,
he has put together an exciting
display of Twain's life and work
at the University's
Blackhawk Museum.
>> The language that
you and I speak
with its peculiar
American qualities,
was put down on paper
by this man.
>> Notice his handwriting.
>> At the museum,
visitors immerse themselves
in the issues Twain wrote about,
from racial equality to love.
A passionate love letter
to his future wife is here
for everybody to read.
>> I love love love love love
you, and multiplied by 150.
And so loving you,
I note your faults,
ignite them with my love.
>> What do you think
that Mark Twain feels
about this wonderful woman?
>> He was really
in love with her.
>> Yeah.
>> Twain spent a lot of
time on the lecture circuit
to gain fame and money.
His lecture notes from 1896
help explain the crucial passage
in Huck Finn published
12 years earlier,
where Huck is debating
whether to turn
in Jim as a runaway slave.
>> Huck is prepared to turn Jim
in, yet he finally concludes
that he cannot do that.
His heart wins out and his
conscience suffers a defeat.
This was the most popular
component of his lecture
on this grand tour of the world.
[ Applause ]
>> Lee Ann Potter:
So good morning.
I'm so happy to see all of you.
So glad to have -- be able
to welcome you to the Library
of Congress this morning
and to the Ninth Annual Jonah
S. Eskin Memorial Lecture.
It's really a lecture though.
Today's going to be more of a
presentation and a conversation.
And we're delighted
to have all of you.
We're also delighted to have our
author, Philip Stead, with us.
And before we get started
with the rest of our program,
I've got a couple
of remarks for you.
I'm Lee Ann Potter.
I direct educational outreach
here at the Library of Congress.
And along with my colleagues
in educational outreach
and our Young Reader Center,
we want to welcome you.
And we also want to
shout out to you,
because we know who
all of you are.
Before I do the roll call of
the various schools that are
in the room though,
I want to mention
that this week is
Children's Book Week.
It is the longest-running
national literacy program,
or initiative, in
the United States.
It's sponsored by the
Children's Book Council,
as well as Every Child a Reader.
And along with schools and
libraries around the country,
this week is dedicated to
celebrating the joy of reading.
So we're happy that
you're with us today
to help us celebrate
the joy of reading.
All of you before you leave,
will be receiving a copy
of this year's book week poster.
So make sure you get
those on your way out.
They were illustrated by
Jillian Tamaki, and given to us
by the Children's Book Council.
So a nice thank you to the
Children's Book Council.
Also, I want to make another
shout out as a thank you
to my colleagues -- to
Karen Jaffe, to Sasha Dowdy,
to Monica Valentine, the
rest of educational outreach,
as well as our multimedia team,
for making this morning
possible.
Thanks, you guys.
So we have sixth, seventh, and
eighth-graders here with us
from School Without
Walls at Francis Stevens.
We have sixth-graders
from Washington Global Public
Charter School [applause].
We also have sixth
and seventh-graders
from Stuart-Hobson
Middle School [applause].
We have sixth-graders from
St. Patrick's Episcopal
School [applause].
We also have students
from Northern Virginia,
including students in
grades three through six
from the River Farm Cooperative
School in Alexandria [applause].
And I guess I should say
this a little louder.
We also have seventh
and eighth-graders
from the Mark Twain Middle
School [applause] in Alexandria.
We're also live-streaming
this program.
And we know that we've got
schools and individuals
in various parts of the
United States watching.
So if you guys want to turn
around and wave to them,
so they know we're glad
that they are tuning in.
And I really I need to do a --
we have some interns in
our Young Reader Center
who did some homework last week
to find as many middle schools
in the United States
that are named
for Mark Twain as they could.
And they sent out special notes
to those schools telling
them about this event.
So hopefully we've got some
other Mark Twain schools
tuning in.
I'm excited about that.
So thank you all for coming.
Oh, and by the way, because
we're live-streaming the
program, there will be
a recording available.
So if you really get
into the program today,
you can watch it again later
and you can show your
friends and family, okay.
You'll all do that, right?
Yeah. Because the Library of
Congress has a YouTube channel,
and I know you all follow it.
And we're on Facebook.
So today's program
is about Mark Twain,
but it's just sort
of about Mark Twain.
How many of you --
raise your hands
if you think you know a thing
or two about Mark Twain.
Okay, all right, some
good hands going up.
So as you learned from the
video that we showed you,
Mark Twain was a writer.
He was a lecturer.
He was a humorist.
He was also a publisher.
And we're going to learn a
little bit more about him today,
but we're also going to
focus not just on Mark Twain
but really we're going
to focus on the work
of this guy and his wife.
So Philip Stead is
with us today,
and he's got an incredible
story to tell you
about Mark Twain that's very
closely connected to the papers
of Mark Twain that you got
a glimpse of in the video.
And with all of our programs
here at the Library Congress,
we like to make sure that we
understand what the connection
to the Library and its
collections might be
with whatever topic
we're focused on.
So we did a little digging.
And not only are there
Mark Twain papers
in the Bancroft Library
out in California,
but there are some terrific
Mark Twain materials here
in the Library of Congress.
One of them is up on the screen.
In 1874, Mark Twain --
who of course his real
name was Samuel Clemens --
he wrote a letter to the
Librarian of Congress.
And he did so because he had
written a series of sketches
and he wanted to ensure that
his work was being copyrighted.
You can go ahead and
hit that next slide.
So he's writing to -- this is
in May of 1874, and he's writing
to the then Librarian of
Congress, Ainsworth Spofford.
He says, "Dear sir, I enclose a
design of a pamphlet cover upon
which I desire copyright.
Also, the title page of the
pamphlet, upon the contents
of which I likewise
desire copyright.
Fees, $1, enclosed.
Very truly yours,
Samuel Clemens."
So we have to say, we love
it when we come across things
like this in the
Library's collection.
So a handwritten letter
from Mark Twain related
to copywriting some of his work.
But not only does the Library of
Congress hold original letters,
but the Library also has
an enormous collection
of newspapers and magazines
and many, many, many --
literally millions of them --
are available through
the Library's Chronicling
America website.
And the next slide,
which shows you one
of those political cartoons
in one of those magazines,
Harper's Weekly, that
shows Mark Twain as well.
And I know that in your
textbooks and other materials,
sometimes -- go ahead
and click it again --
you often see things like
the political cartoon,
but you miss the context.
You sort of miss that
it originally appeared
in the newspaper, and that's
the fun part about looking
at original sources, is you see
where they originally came from.
I want to say one more thing
about the video that we watched.
We were so excited about this.
A couple of years ago,
the Library entered
into a partnership
with WGBH TV Boston.
It's a public TV station.
And because of that partnership,
the American Archive
of Public Broadcasting
was established.
And through the American Archive
of Public Broadcasting website,
you can access literally
thousands
of public television programs
like the one we watched.
So when we started digging
around the website and came
across that entire film --
and it's a lot longer than what
we saw -- related to Mark Twain,
we were pretty excited.
So another shout out to the fact
that the Library's collections
come in a huge variety of media,
from motion picture
films to newspapers
and periodicals to manuscripts.
Library collections are so much
fun, they're not just books.
But if they were books
and you happen to go
on the Library's website,
and you happen to do a search
on Mark Twain in the
main card catalog,
guess how many times you'd
find Mark Twain's name?
Not in the millions,
but about 3000.
There are about 3000 books
in the Library's collection
that are either written by
Mark Twain or about Mark Twain.
That's a lot.
3000, that's incredible.
And they're not just
in English either,
lots of those materials are in
languages other than English.
Okay, so enough about
the Library
of Congress and its collection.
But what I love most about
all of those materials
and the reason we wanted
to highlight them is
to really emphasize to you
that the materials that are
in the Library often
speak to us.
They inspire us.
They are the ideas and the
thoughts and often the voices
of not only people who are
living today but people
who lived in the past.
And our speaker today
certainly has a story
in that vein to tell us.
So I'm going to do my official
introduction of Philip now.
So here we go.
It is my great pleasure to
introduce our very patient
and award-winning
author, Philip Stead,
who with his illustrator
wife, Erin Stead,
wrote the exceptional and
unique book, "The Purloining
of Prince Leo Margarine."
[ Applause ]
Philip also wrote "A
Sick Day for Amos McGee,"
which was the 2011 Caldecott
award-winning illustrated book
by his wife and him.
"Bear Has a Story to Tell,"
"Lenny and Lucy," "Hello,
my Name is Ruby," "Jonathan
and the Big Blue Boat,"
and "A Home for Bird."
I suspect some of those
titles are familiar.
Now here's the opportunity
you've been waiting for.
How did Philip Stead
find the unfinished draft
from Mark Twain?
And what did it take to complete
and become a published work?
>> Philip Stead:
All right, well,
thanks for having me, everybody.
This is kind of a treat for me.
I very rarely get to speak
to middle schoolers
or high schoolers.
I normally am talking
to very young children
or I'm talking to adults.
And so I flew in last
night from Michigan,
and I had a few hours
that were free.
And so I had dinner with
somebody I hadn't seen
since I was in high school.
I went to middle school
with this person too.
And I was talking to
her and she said --
she was the valedictorian
of our school, by the way.
We were talking about what I
was going be presenting today,
and she was asking me a lot of
questions, and then she said,
you should tell them
about how you used
to skip school all the time.
And I said, I absolutely
should not tell them that.
And so I'm on record not
telling you that right now.
I absolutely never skipped
middle school or high school.
So I'm an author.
I'm also an illustrator.
I've either written
or illustrated
about 15 different books,
with about five or six more
to come in the near future.
These three books
are the three books
that I made with my wife, Erin.
Erin could not be here
today, but she was the artist
in all three of these books,
and she's also the artist
for this Mark Twain
collaboration that I'm going
to be talking about today.
A little bit about
myself before I begin.
I'm from the state of Michigan.
Has anybody here ever been
to the state of Michigan?
That's not too bad.
I love Michigan.
One of the reasons
I love Michigan is
because there's so much water.
I grew up down here
near Detroit.
So people from Michigan
like to show their hand
when they're talking
about where they're from,
because Michigan is
shaped like a mitten.
So Detroit is down here.
And now I live way up there.
Do you guys see that
red dot up there?
So I live way up there.
And then do you see an
island sort of right
above that, a big island?
Okay, so remember that island,
we're going to come back
to that in a minute.
I think it's important
to know where a person --
where an author is from,
because I think something
about where you're from will
inevitably sort of creep
into the types of
things you make.
I think that's absolutely true
of Mark Twain, who as you heard
in the video, was from all
over, but really I believe he's
from Hannibal, Missouri.
That's where he was born.
He was born along the
Mississippi River.
And I think there's something
about being from that place
that has infected
everything he's written.
When you live along the river,
I imagine that you're always
seeing people coming and going
in there's constant
motion and things coming
into town and out of town.
And when I read Mark
Twain's work,
that's what sticks out to me.
There's always a
coming and a going
in his books and in his stories.
They're always are
traveling stories.
I think the water is
important to me too.
Michigan is surrounded by water.
And this is right -- this may be
five minutes from where I live.
People think of Michigan and
maybe they imagine something
that looks more like
Ohio, like flat farmland.
But when I think of Michigan,
I think of beaches and I think
of big open expanses of water.
And when I want to be -- when
I want to be quiet and I want
to think about my thoughts and
want to think about my writing,
I go to the water, and I sit
in quiet places near the water.
I live in an old farmhouse,
and beside the old
farmhouse is a big red barn.
My wife Erin and I have turned
the red barn into an art studio.
So this is the inside
of the studio.
And the upstairs, when
you walk upstairs,
it's just a library,
it's all books.
So when we don't have any
ideas, we just go upstairs
and we sit near other
people's ideas.
And then once we've got an idea,
we go back downstairs and we sit
at our desks and
we begin to draw.
Does anybody here consider
themselves an artist?
Yeah. So I think I
was 10 years old --
I think I was 10 years old
when I was given my
first drafting table.
A drafting table is one of
those tables it sort of lifts
up like this so you can
draw closer to your face.
And I think it's really
important as an artist
or an author either one to
have a space that you work.
And it doesn't have to be as
big and open as this barn.
It can be a corner in a room.
It can be in your closet.
I remember when I was
very little, I used to go
in my closet and lock
the door and that's
where I would work
on my projects.
But it's important to be
alone with yourself sometimes.
So that brings us to
Mark Twain and the story
of how the story came to be.
So in the year 1879, Mark Twain
was in a hotel room in Paris,
and he was telling a
story to his own children.
This is something that he
would do almost every night,
and we know that because he
would write about these moments
in his diaries and his journals.
And the way it would
normally work is one
of his daughters would bring
a magazine or a newspaper.
They would open up to a page and
they would point at an image.
And from that image,
Mark Twain --
it was Mark Twain's job to come
up with a story for
his daughters.
And sometimes it was successful.
Sometimes it was
not so successful.
But we never really had
any actual evidence,
written evidence, of
any of these stories
that survived to
the present day.
So fast-forward all the
way to the year 2011.
There's a man named
Dr. John Bird.
He was a professor
from North Carolina.
And he was out at that archive
that we just saw on the video,
in Berkeley, California,
and he was doing research
for a Mark Twain cookbook.
He wanted write a cookbook
based on food and recipes
that could be found in
Mark Twain's writings.
So he had the researchers
pulling out any file folder
that had anything at
all to do with food.
So there was one folder and it
was just labeled oleomargarine,
which today we would
call margarine,
which is something you'd
find at the grocery store.
It's kind of like butter.
We always had margarine in the
refrigerator when I was a kid.
So when they open
up this folder,
instead of finding
anything about food,
what they found were 16
pages of handwritten notes
for this children's story
that Mark Twain had told his
daughters in Paris that night.
This was enormous news in
the Mark Twain universe.
Because it's not every day that
you find something brand-new
from the most famous
and important American
writer who has ever lived.
Interestingly enough
though, so at some point
in the hundred plus years
between the original telling
and when it was discovered,
somebody had actually pulled it
out of the archive, thought
that maybe it was a
little bit illegible,
people wouldn't be
able to read it,
and decided to type the entire
thing up on a typewriter
and just stick it right back in
the folder and forget about it.
So this thing had actually
been discovered before,
but the person who discovered
it the first time didn't realize
the importance.
So this is actually
what was given to me.
It was not a completed story,
it was notes for a story.
And I was asked to
please find a way
to complete Mark
Twain's original idea.
So this is a daunting task, but
right away I began making notes
on that original -- on
this original document.
Sometimes I agreed
with what Mark Twain --
the ways in which Mark
Twain was telling the story.
Sometimes almost immediately, in
fact, I found ways to take issue
with what Mark Twain was
doing with his story.
For example, Mark
Twain had right
on this very first page a
main character in his story,
named Susie, which is also
the name of his daughter.
And that character
was a kangaroo.
I felt that this was a
mistake that he had made.
Mark Twain loved kangaroos,
which you can actually --
you can learn a lot
about Mark Twain.
And that's one thing that
comes up again and again,
Mark Twain loved kangaroos.
But as a storyteller
that works specifically
in children's literature
like I do, I know something
about kangaroos that he doesn't.
Which is that if you put
a kangaroo in your story,
you just made your story
in a very specific place
in a very specific country.
What country is that?
>> Australia.
>> Philip Stead: Exactly.
So every kid everywhere knows
that kangaroos are
from Australia.
And I really didn't think
that Mark Twain wanted
to set this book in Australia.
So I crossed off kangaroo
and I made that character
into a skunk, which is made some
Mark Twain professors very angry
with me.
So what I got was 4
1/2 pages of notes.
And at the end of this last
page, the story just ends.
There's no official
ending to the story,
there's just the point at
which he stopped taking notes.
And there was never
a clear answer
as to whether the final pages
of the manuscript were missing,
or if Mark Twain never got
around to writing them,
or maybe there never
was an ending.
I'm of the opinion that there
actually never was an ending
to this story.
Because this is a story that
Mark Twain was telling out loud,
probably over the
course of several nights.
And so there didn't really
need to be an ending.
It was the kind of story
that just continues
to have new material every
night when he would sit
down with his children.
But that doesn't really work if
you're trying to make a book.
A book needs to have an ending.
So you can see my own
handwriting at the end.
That was the very first thing
I wrote for this project,
where I get to the ending,
and I just write, then what?
And that was my task:
figuring out then what.
So for me that meant
going very far away.
And very far away for
me meant an island
in the middle of Lake Michigan.
So you remember that island that
was just north of where I live?
That's called Beaver Island.
And I had never been to Beaver
Island, which is not unusual,
because very few people have
ever been to Beaver Island.
This is what it looks like from
the airplane that I had to take
as I was leaving the island.
There's very few buildings.
It doesn't look anything
like Washington, DC.
There is a tiny, tiny town
at the very far end,
and then that's it.
There's about three
buildings and a light house.
There's only one road that cuts
down the middle of the island.
So I originally arrived
on that on a boat.
I had my bicycle.
I rode all the way to a cabin
that was owned by
a friend of mine.
The cabin had no phone.
It had no Internet.
It had no television.
It had no radio.
And I had decided that I was
going to stay at this cabin
until I had written something.
It's -- the hardest part of any
project I think is beginning.
And I can put off working
on something forever,
if I don't get to it right away.
So that's why I ended
up on this island.
As I'm riding my bike
around the island though,
I kept encountering these
signs along the side the road.
And the signs were all talking
about this man named
James Jesse Strang,
who I had never heard of.
And I knew nothing
about the history
of Beaver Island before I
arrived there with my bicycle.
This is where the story --
the story of Beaver Island
is strange, but it's also
where the story of the making of
this book becomes very strange.
In the 1850s, the
Mormon Church was led
by a man named Joseph Smith.
Joseph Smith died.
And then there were several
people that were sort of vying
for control of who would be in
charge of the Mormon Church.
So there was a man named
Brigham Young, who took a bunch
of his followers out
to the state of Utah.
And that's why so many followers
of the Mormon Church
still live in Utah today.
But then there was also this
man named James Jesse Strang,
who took his followers
to Beaver Island.
When he arrived at
Beaver Island,
he decided that he had
had a revelation from God.
And that revelation was that
he should be named King,
King of Beaver Island.
This was very funny to
me, that there was a King
of Beaver Island that
I had never heard of.
I learned shortly thereafter
-- you know, I'm riding my bike
down the road, I end up at a
different sign and it says,
this is the spot where
James Jesse Strang issued a
particularly unpopular
proclamation
and then he got himself killed.
So this again was
very funny to me.
And it seemed like
exactly the kind of story
that Mark Twain himself
would've been really interested
in hearing.
Because Mark Twain
was always interested
in how American history,
American politics,
American religion all kind of
mixed together to make one sort
of uncomfortable story.
So I didn't know what to do
with all this information.
It seemed important to me.
It seemed important
because it was something
that I thought Mark Twain
would be interested in.
It also seemed important to
me because it was a story
about a king and a kingdom,
and here I was working
on a fairytale that was
about a king and a kingdom.
And so I couldn't figure
out exactly how but I knew
that I wanted these two
things to go together.
And I was worried that I was
already sort of going off
in a wrong direction and
Mark Twain maybe wouldn't be
so happy with me.
But then my very last
day on the island,
I pull a book off of the shelf.
So again, I'm at a library.
It's a much smaller library,
but it's a library just
inside this little cabin.
Pull a book off the shelf
and a page falls out.
The book was a little
paperback of stories
and essays by Mark Twain.
And this quote was on
the page that fell out.
It says, "narrative should
flow as flows the brook
down through the hills
and the leafy woodlands,
its course changed by every
boulder it comes across
and by every grass
clad gravelly spur
that projects into its path.
Its surface unbroken but it's
course not stayed by rocks
and gravel in the bottom
in the shoal places.
A brook that never goes
straight for a minute
but goes and goes briskly.
Sometimes ungrammatically,
and sometimes fetching a
horseshoe three-quarters
of a mile around.
And at the end of the
circuit, flowing within a yard
of the path it traversed
an hour before.
But always going and always
following at least one law.
Always loyal to that law,
the law of narrative,
which has no law."
And I love that last sentence,
the law of narrative
which has no law.
And I really felt like that was
Mark Twain giving me permission
to tell this story in any
way that was necessary.
And I really felt
that that was the way
that Mark Twain would want
me to tell this story.
But then began -- after I
come back from the island,
I get something down on paper.
It's really not a
finished story yet,
but at least I've got something.
I really felt like I
needed to do more research,
to really understand
who Mark Twain was.
So there were sort of two ways
to approach how to
write this story.
One would be to try to
predict every single word
that Mark Twain would've said.
And right away I felt like
that was a recipe for failure.
There is no way to really know
over a hundred years later
what Mark Twain would've said.
But what I could
do is get to know
who Mark Twain was
as best I could.
And if I could know who Mark
Twain was, then I might be able
to tell a story that
he would be happy with,
that he would be proud of,
that would honor the spirit
of Mark Twain, instead of trying
to be literal about the way
that he would've told the story.
One of our first
stops that my wife
and I took was to this house.
So this was Mark Twain's
house in Connecticut.
This is where he lived
when he wrote many
of his most famous works.
It's the house that his
children grew up in.
It's a big, beautiful,
elaborate house.
It's so big, I really couldn't
even fit it all into a picture.
So I'm just showing you
one little piece of it.
This is Mark Twain's
personal writing room.
This was my favorite
place in the house.
It's got his billiard table.
That desk in the back is where
he would sit and do his writing.
What I really loved
about this house is that,
even though it's --
today it's a museum.
And even though it's a big,
beautiful, elaborate house,
it really still felt
like a home.
So when you walk into it, you
really feel that this is a place
where a family that
loved each other lived.
You can imagine the
stories being told.
It didn't at all
feel like a museum.
Another piece of research that
was really important to me --
there are actually two more
pieces I want talk about.
One is the autobiography of
Mark Twain, which was published
in three volumes, and
when you stack them
up together, it's
about this tall.
What was so important about the
autobiography of Mark Twain is
that he had stipulated he
didn't want it published
until 100 years after his death.
The reason being is that he
had put all of his grievances
into that autobiography,
all the things
that he was feeling irritable
about, all the things
that were bothering
him, maybe about --
there was a whole section
about copyright at the Library
of Congress that
he was upset about.
And he was able to
put information
down in a very honest way that
he may have felt inhibited --
more inhibited if
it was something
for publication while
he was still alive.
In addition to that, he didn't
actually write the biography.
What he did is he spoke it.
He tried and failed
several times in his life
to work on his autobiography.
And towards the end of his life,
he realized that the best way
for him to go about it was
not to start with the day
of his birth and just write
down every single
instance along the way
until his eventual death.
What he wanted to do was
just wake up in the morning,
and before he even got out
of bed, just start speaking
about whatever it was
that was on his mind.
And somebody else in the room
would be writing it down.
This was hugely important
for me.
Because the story
I was writing began
as what we would call a
piece of oral history.
So it was a story that was
spoken out loud in real time
between Mark Twain
and his daughters.
And here I had pages
and pages and pages
of Mark Twain oral history.
And I think we all know
that the way that you speak
out loud is different from the
way that you write on paper.
And there might be some
overlap between the two,
but I really needed to get
to know the Mark Twain
that spoke aloud.
And that's a much harder
Mark Twain to find.
The other piece of research
that was really important
for me was a biography
written by Mark Twain
by his 12-year-old
daughter, Susie.
This was probably the
most important piece of --
the most important original
document that I came across.
Here we have a quote
from that biography.
So she's 12 years old, and
she writes about her father.
"He couldn't bear to hear
anyone talk but himself.
But he could listen to
himself talk for hours
without getting tired."
So I could find no
other instance
of anybody writing
critically about Mark Twain.
Anybody that was willing
to acknowledge what kind
of flaws did this person have.
Although Susie thought
her father was very funny,
she thought he was very brave,
she thought he was
very intelligent.
She also had critiques
of her father.
And I wanted to know
those critiques.
Mark Twain would also be writing
down notes in his own journals
and diaries about Susie.
So here's one that says,
"apparently Susie was born
with humane feelings
for the animals
and compassion for
their troubles."
That was one of my favorite
quotes that I came across.
Because that's when I recognized
that if this was a story
that Mark Twain was telling to
his own children and to Susie
in particular -- who I think
was his favorite daughter --
and Susie was a child who had
a lot of love and compassion
for animals, then
love and compassion
for animals should be
a part of this story,
even if it's not a part
of the original notes.
Here's another quote from Susie,
and this quote is actually
at the very beginning of the
book when you open up the book.
It says, "I have wanted
Papa to write a book
that would reveal something of
his kind, sympathetic nature."
This, you know, as
I'm talking right now,
I think that this was actually
probably the most important
single piece of information
that Erin and I stumbled across.
Because Mark Twain --
you have to imagine.
He's not just a famous
author, he's the most famous
and important person on the
entire planet when he was alive.
He's less like a famous author,
more like say Kanye West.
So he was the Kanye
West of his day.
Because of that, I think it was
very difficult for Mark Twain
to be honest when
he was in public.
He felt a real burden
to always be funny.
I think he felt a real burden
to always be very smart.
He wanted to be the smartest
and funniest man in the room.
But he had a hard time
revealing that part of himself
that was kind and that part of
himself that was vulnerable.
And I really thought
that those parts
of himself would be the kinds of
-- would be the parts of himself
that would be revealed if
he was telling a story just
to his own family.
So this is what my
writing looks like.
And I kind of cringe at the
idea that my own notes will end
up someday, you know,
at the Berkeley Archive
or the Library of Congress.
Because my notes look a lot like
my own middle school homework.
This is the very first
passage from the book.
So it's a note written
by me that sort
of explains how I'm
going to tell the story.
And the way I imagined
myself telling this story was
that I imagined Mark
Twain was there with me
and he was telling me the story,
and now Mark Twain is gone,
and it's my job now to
tell it back to you.
And I'm going to tell it in my
own way, but I'm going to be
as faithful as possible
to the man that told
to me in the first place.
So now I'd like to talk
to you a little bit
about how the artwork was made.
So Erin would normally do
this part of the presentation.
She's at home with our
10-month-old baby right now,
so I'm going to do my best
telling her half of the story.
For Erin the most important
part of the process was coming
up with the main character.
She really felt that there
was no way she could proceed
with this project until she
knew exactly what this character
looked like, exactly how
this character moved.
In this case she really wanted
the character to have two things
that are very difficult to
put into the same person.
She wanted the character to look
vulnerable and compassionate.
She also wanted that
character to look brave.
And these two things, they're
not necessarily opposites
but they're difficult things
to put into the same face.
And so Erin spent nearly
three months working
on just this single drawing.
She would draw it, she
would draw it again.
And eventually she
came across --
or she came to this image of
our main character, Johnny,
that she was happy with.
One thing that Erin does
to find a character is
that she'll actually sculpt
the character with clay.
For Erin that's easier
sometimes than just trying
to draw unto a empty white page.
She can just get her thumbs
in there, start moving around.
What does the nose look like?
What does the eye look like?
What does the character
look like when you turn it?
Does it look good
from all angles?
And when she's got
a clay head --
this is about three inches
tall maybe in real life.
And once she's got
that finished,
what she can do is move it
around and draw from it.
That way you're not
always having
to use just your imagination.
Erin uses all old-fashioned
and traditional materials,
which is one of the reasons
I think we were asked
to work on this project.
Mark Twain -- when Mark
Twain was alive and writing,
the most common form of book
illustration was probably wood
block printing.
In its day would've been
in almost every book
that you would see
that would have images.
These days it's much
less common.
But it's the way that
Erin continues to work.
So on the right side here
we have her carving knives
that she uses for
carving wood blocks.
And on the left are
just her pencils
that she uses to
finish the images.
So these are Erin's
paints and her brayers
and what's called a bear and the
little circular object is called
the baren.
The way Erin works is
she'll carve a wood block.
She'll add ink or paint to
that wood block using one
of those brayers.
It's kind of like
a paint roller.
Then she'll press a piece of
paper onto that wood block
and then take that circular
baren, and with the pressure
of her own hand,
will press the ink
from the wood block
onto the paper.
In the center there
is Erin's color chart.
So there are -- let's
see -- 15 colors there.
That's every color that Erin
is going to use in the book.
Before Erin makes
a single image,
what she does is
decides the color palette
for the entire book.
So this is one of
Erin's wood blocks.
This is the wood block -- one
of the wood blocks that was used
to make the cover image.
So she carved that big shape
that's sort of all smeared
in red right now,
that's the dragon.
And then underneath the
dragon's head is the lion.
After she's added the ink
and then pressed the paper,
she pulls the paper up, it
looks something like this.
And then the final step is
several hours with her just
with her pencil box
where she starts filling
in all the details.
So this is the image, this
is the cover image for the
"The Purloining of
Prince Oleomargarine."
Erin also uses the wood blocks
in a nontraditional way.
So typically you would always
be carving away things.
But one thing that Erin likes
to do is to add ink directly
onto the block and to sort
of wipe it softly away
just with a paper towel.
And by doing that, she can
get an image that looks kind
of like this with these
soft edges for the ground
and these soft edges
for the clouds,
which then became an image
that looks like this.
So one of the challenges
that Erin was facing was,
what is the setting
for this book?
It was told originally in 1879.
We are illustrating it at
this time in 2014, 2015, 2016.
But it's a fairytale
at the same time.
And fairytales aren't usually
set, well, in Australia for one.
They're also not set in the
United States typically.
We kind of felt that Mark
Twain would want to buck trend
and he would want this book
set in the United States.
And so what we decided
to do was bridge the gap
between Mark Twain's era and
our own era and to set the book
in what's known as
the Dust Bowl.
So the middle of the country
in the 1930s basically.
It's a really desolate,
dusty place,
and we thought it was
perfect for the kind of story
that Mark Twain would tell.
So you guys see the house up
there in the upper right corner?
Throughout the book, Erin
dropped in little things
that were -- she would
call them Easter eggs.
Things for people that really
love Mark Twain to find
so that they could engage with
the book in a special way.
So that house was
actually based on the house
that Mark Twain was born
in, which is seen here.
The queen in this story, who
doesn't show up until later
on in the story, was actually
based on Mark Twain's wife.
Which some people have noticed.
There was one final piece of
the creation of the artwork
that really was giving us
trouble for a long time.
There were certain elements that
we really wanted to be carved
in wood and printed, but they
were just either they were too
intricate to carve by hand, or
it would just take us too long.
So what we ended up doing was
using a laser to carve the wood,
which involves a
lot of me standing
and watching this machine work.
So this is what I'm
looking at there.
All of the chapter titles in the
book -- so it says chapter 2,
regarding parades, chapter
1, in which we are introduced
to our luckless hero -- all of
these chapter titles were carved
into wood using this
laser machine.
There are also use these
long proclamations,
the proclamations -- the
unpopular proclamations --
of the king, that would've taken
us literally months to carve
by hand, that we
were able to carve
in maybe 45 minutes
using this machine.
These are some of my favorite
pieces of artwork in the book.
This is what that
king's proclamation looks
like in the final book.
This is what one of the
chapter titles looks like.
Maybe my favorite
individual carving
in this book is actually
on the endpapers.
Can I see the book here?
So an endpaper is the
part of the book --
the very first thing
when you open the book
and the very last thing you
see when you close the book.
And in most books this
will just be a solid color,
or maybe it'll just
be plain white.
But Erin and I love to
do something special
for the endpapers
whenever we can.
So we wanted to bring the whole
project back to where it began.
We wanted people to be
able to see a little bit
of what Mark Twain's
actual writing looked like.
So we took some original
pages of Mark Twain's work.
We had them digitized.
Then we were able to feed
those into the laser carver.
And Mark Twain's actual
writing started to get spit
out by this laser carver
directly into the wood.
And this is an image
of Erin pulling a print
from Mark Twain's handwriting.
So these are some of my
favorite pieces of artwork.
So that brings us
to the conclusion.
One of the questions that I get
more than an when I'm talking
about this book is: Which part
of the book was Mark Twain's
and which part of
the book is yours?
And the obvious answer,
the most obvious answer is
that the ending is mine.
The last few pages of the
book are completely mine.
But in truth, that doesn't
really tell you the story.
Because all throughout the
text, he and I are sort
of interweaving and
sometimes it's him speaking
and sometimes it's me speaking.
And I worked very hard and it
was very difficult for me to try
to find a way to
balance our two voices.
My favorite example of something
that's neither Mark Twain nor
myself but is also
both is this chicken.
So the chicken is my favorite
character in the entire book.
And the chicken's name
is pestilence and famine.
So as I was doing my
research on Mark Twain,
one of the things
I discovered is
that Mark Twain always
had cats in his house.
Just cats and cats everywhere,
when he lived on the farm
in Elmira, New York, there were
cats in and out of the house
and in his writing studio.
And the cats always
had strange names.
One of those cats was named
pestilence and famine.
Or -- and we could
never really figure this
out -- there were two cats.
One that was named pestilence
and one that was famine.
The reason we couldn't
figure it out is
because nobody had
bothered to put a comma
where you would need
to put a comma.
And we could never find a
satisfactory answer to whether
or not there were
two cats or one cat.
But Erin and I thought
it was funnier
if there was only one cat
and the cat had two names.
So that's why this chicken
was introduced into the story
as pestilence and famine,
one chicken has two names.
And that's my favorite example
of something that's both
a little bit of Twain
and a little bit of me and
a little bit of Erin too.
And an example of the kind of
thinking that we were using
as we were making this project.
>> Lee Ann Potter: It's great.
I love this story.
Isn't it a great story?
[ Applause ]
I'm really glad that
you made a point
of mentioning how
you start the book.
I want to read you guys
something real quick.
And he says at the very
beginning, it's the note
from one of the authors.
And he showed you his
handwriting version of this,
but the part that I really
get a kick out of is,
"Most likely you don't know me
and you've never heard my name,
said too fast or otherwise.
Chances are though you've
heard of my friend, Mark Twain.
He's the one who
told me this story."
I love that.
I have a feeling you guys
have some questions for him.
I love this notion that
something that he's just shared
with you, either about his
work or the story itself,
probably has spoken to you
and you've got questions.
So we've got four microphones
all around our room.
And when you raise
your hand and one
of my colleagues identifies you,
if you would take the microphone
and say your name and
then ask your question,
that would be great.
Why don't we start right here?
>> Hi. I'm Jaden.
And I wanted to ask what you --
what do you inspire to be
most like, like Mark Twain?
>> Philip Stead: Well, if
I could grow a mustache
like Mark Twain, I think
that'd be pretty great.
I think -- so I learned
a lot about Mark Twain
as I was working on this.
And one thing that
I really admire is
that Mark Twain was really well
known for being able to stand
up in front of people, and
he would just sort of stand
and wait for everybody
to get really quiet,
and then he would
just start talking.
And he could tell
a story like that.
And that really is
impressive to me.
Because it took me three
years to write this story.
And I think Mark Twain could
have done in about 15 minutes.
So that's what I aspire to be.
I aspire to be somebody who
can just get up, tell a story,
and have it be perfect
on the first try.
>> Lee Ann Potter: Good answer.
Oh, I want to mention
as well for those of you
who are watching
our live-stream,
if you want to ask a question,
you can through Twitter,
if you use the #TwainLOC.
So if you're on Twitter and
you want to ask a question,
if you if you just
use the #TwainLOC,
my colleague Sasha has her
phone ready and she can be
on the lookout for any
of those questions.
Okay. How about we go --
do we have a question
back there, or not?
Great.
>> Hi. My name is Eleanor.
And I was wondering
what the like connection
between all the characters was
and how they were all connected?
>> Philip Stead: The
question was how are all the
characters connected.
So this is a difficult
one to answer.
Because Mark Twain sort of
had his own way in his notes
of connecting the characters,
but then I had my own ideas
for how characters
ought to be connected.
But there are certain characters
that were the same throughout.
So the character of Johnny, we
were very faithful to the way
that Mark Twain wrote
about that character.
Also the character of the
queen, who I think was --
we based it on Mark Twain's
wife, who he loved very much.
But I think that even if he
wasn't quite thinking that,
that was a character that he
was particularly in love with.
But there were so many
different options.
One of the things I love about
this story is that there were
so many pieces of
information that were missing.
And that's what was really
exciting as a storyteller,
is that because there were
so many pieces missing,
it allowed us to
make the connections
and to put things together in a
way that felt appropriate to us.
>> Hi. My name is Cooper.
And what made you like
Mark Twain so much?
>> Philip Stead: So that's
an interesting question,
because there were times when
I would say that I didn't
like Mark Twain very much.
We spent so much
time working with him
as if he were a real live
person, that we started to feel
that Mark Twain was almost
like a family member.
So you love your family,
but sometimes you just really
can't stand your family either.
And the more that we read about
Mark Twain and the more we had
to spend time with him, there
were times when we just felt
like maybe it would be better,
Mark, if you would just leave
and we could work on this thing
by our self for a little while.
But he never left.
And now I feel like Mark
Twain is permanently living
in my spare bedroom.
>> My name is Zoe Ridell.
I was wondering what's your
10-month-old baby's name?
>> My 10-month-old
baby's name is Adelaide,
which is actually a
city in Australia.
So Australia has come back
into the conversation.
>> My name is Ty.
And I had a question about
when you went into the house,
did you feel like a flashback
or anything that you felt inside
that could've put in your books?
>> Philip Stead: Do you mean
like in Mark Twain's house?
>> Yes.
>> Philip Stead:
So a little bit.
The funny thing is when
you walk into that house,
it really does feel like there
are ghosts in that house.
And it's not a house that
I would want to be hanging
around in after dark,
I'll say that.
>> Hello, my name is Avery.
And was the title of your
book Mark Twain's title,
or did you make that title?
>> Philip Stead: That's
a very good question.
So Mark Twain didn't
leave a title.
All he wrote was the word
"oleomargarine" on the top.
And so it was our job also
to come up with the title.
Purloining was my
editor's favorite word.
Well, she has two
favorite words.
One is purloining,
which means --
if you don't know
what this word means,
it kind of means it's
something like stealing,
kind of like kidnapping
in this case.
Her other favorite
word is defenestration,
which means to throw
yourself out a window.
But I worked tirelessly to
try to get the second word
into the book and never
was able to do it.
>> Sasha?
>> Hi, mane is Destinee.
And my question was is there
like a spiritual connection
with Mark Twain, or
is he still alive?
>> Philip Stead:
So Mark Twain died
in I think it was the year 1910.
But for me he is very
much still alive.
So I guess yeah, you
would call it kind
of a spiritual connection.
>> My name is Suleiman.
And my question was if those
aren't all the characters,
then how did you pick which
characters to put on the cover?
>> Philip Stead: So that was
up to my wife, Erin, to decide.
And all of the important
characters
in the book are there.
So the characters that
have either speaking roles
or play some other
sort of important role.
And there are a lot of animals
in the book that are sort
of I guess you'd call them
background in the story.
And so it was -- Erin was trying
very hard to put the most --
all the most important
characters --
which would include the
chicken, the skunk, the lion.
On top of the tiger
there is the weasel.
The weasel is very important
to the telling of the story.
And then of course the dragon.
Which was so big that
she couldn't even fit him
on the front cover,
so he goes all the way
on to the back cover too.
>> My name is Austin.
And I was wondering how many
drafts did you have to do?
>> Philip Stead: Another very
good question, how many drafts?
So my very first draft was the
version of the book that I wrote
when I was at the
cabin on Beaver Island.
But I didn't stop writing the
entire time we were working
on the book.
So I began writing
in September of 2014,
and we finished the
book in January of 2017.
So around 2 1/2 years of writing
and rewriting and rewriting.
And the way that I work, I
don't start at the beginning
of a draft and work
all the way to the end.
I just have the entire
thing in front of me
and I change a little bit here
and I change a little bit there
and then I go back to the middle
and I change a little bit here.
So I can't really tell you
exactly how many drafts,
but what I can tell you is
that I was constantly working
and constantly changing.
>> Hello. My name's Wesley.
And I was wondering if
Mark Twain had an influence
on any of your other books?
>> Philip Stead: I
love that question.
So did Mark Twain
have an influence
on any of my other books?
I think he didn't necessarily
have a direct influence
on my books, but I do think he
had an influence on the type
of writer that I became.
People have a lot of different
ways to describe Mark Twain,
but one of the ways that people
like to describe him
is as a satirist.
So a satirist is somebody
who finds a way to use comedy
to better inform people
about some serious
issue that's going on.
And that's always been a
really interesting way for me
to communicate, something
that has influenced me even
though maybe there's not a
specific book of Mark Twain's
that I would look
to for inspiration.
>> Hi. My name is Shakala.
And I was wondering where
did you find the notes
for to write the book?
>> Philip Stead: So the notes --
do you remember the video
we watched at the beginning?
That was the Mark Twain Papers,
which is its own little archive
and library in Berkeley,
California.
So at the time that
they made that video --
which I'm guessing was
about 20 years ago --
they said that there were I
think he said 10,000 letters
to and from Mark Twain.
Today it's all the
way up to over 30,000,
and they're still finding
every single week as many
as three new letters
written to either Mark Twain
or from Mark Twain or from a
family member of Mark Twain's.
And so this archive, it's
really a living thing,
where things are
constantly coming in
and new things are
being discovered.
And there's got to be any number
of little pieces of gold stuck
in this archive waiting to
be discovered by people.
>> My name is Amani.
And I was wondering
why do you think
that you were chosen
to rewrite this book?
>> Philip Stead: I've
asked myself that too,
and I don't have an answer
that I can say is
definitely the true answer.
But what I think is the reason
that we were chosen is actually
the abilities of my wife, Erin.
So I really think that it's
her ability as an artist
and the methods I
was showing you.
How she works in wood block.
She works with all these
traditional materials.
I think that Erin
was really the bridge
between Mark Twain's
era and my own.
And I just kind of came along
because I was attached to her,
that's what I tell
people anyway.
>> Lee Ann Potter: Awesome.
We've got time for
one more question.
And we'll take this one.
>> Hello. So my name is Zozon.
And I got a question.
So before you wrote the book,
did you know what was
in Mark Twain's mind?
Like you don't know what
-- how -- the way it was --
like the book was ended?
Like what was in his mind?
Did you like figure out this?
Or like you took your time?
>> Philip Stead: So
the most difficult part
of this job was figuring
out what was actually inside
the mind of this writer.
And instead of trying to
figure out what was in his mind
on that very specific day,
what I tried to figure
out was what was on his mind
throughout his lifetime.
And if I could figure
out what was
on his mind throughout
his lifetime,
then I would have a better
chance of figuring out the ways
that he would've told the story.
Also, before I leave,
I want to make sure
that somebody gets me
one of these T-shirts
that just says Twain on it.
Because I don't have
anything quite like that.
So if [inaudible]
yeah, that'd be great.
>> Lee Ann Potter: Awesome.
Thank you all so much.
Your questions were terrific.
And Philip, thank you.
>> Philip Stead: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Lee Ann Potter:
I also want to --
I also want to give a
very, very special --
I want to give a very special
thank you to Dr. and Mrs. Eskin
who are here with us, who
made this program possible.
Thank you.
As I mentioned at the
beginning of this program,
Dr. and Mrs. Eskin
are responsible
for the Jonah S. Eskin Memorial
Program here at the Library.
And they've been supporting
this for nine years.
And every one of these programs
I just think are marvelous.
I think your connection to this
story, your way of telling it,
and having it be
about inspiration
and discovery is very much
a part of why you are here.
And so thank you, and thank you.
And thank you to those of you
watching on the life-stream.
We love it when our
audience gets extended.
So thanks to all of you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.GOV.